the laws of reality as we know them
fundamentally rely on the principle
of balance
energy can neither be created nor
destroyed
what goes in
must come out
to the 17th century italian physician
santorio santorio exploring this balance
within the human body led to a
decades-long period of
self-experimentation
for 30 years he weighed every liquid and
solid that went into his body and every
liquid and solid
that came out
he weighed his body before and after a
variety of physical exertions
day in
day out
matter in
mata out
confusingly for him his excretions
failed to measure up to the mass of his
food and drink it was as if a campfire
had been burnt to ashes the wood used as
fuel weighing far greater than the grey
flecks left in its place
but santorio believed the missing matter
had to have gone somewhere it could not
just
cease to exist
and by the end of the 18th century
natural philosophers would definitively
demonstrate santori's base assumption
was true the total amount of mass before
and after a chemical reaction was equal
whether it was the human metabolism
breaking down food into smaller
molecular units of fats proteins and
sugars or the woody fibers in a
campfire's fuel releasing carbon dioxide
and water as it burns
each chemical equation is balanced an
equal number of each kind of atom at the
start of reaction and at the end they
merely rearrange themselves into new
substances
but the very light of day showed us this
kind of balance is not always true
in the 20th century when scientists
unlocked the nuclear power of the atom
it was revealed that the total amount of
mass could indeed change
deep within the core of our sun hydrogen
becomes helium but the total mass
involved in creating this helium is
greater than the mass of the helium
itself and no other matter exists on the
end side of the equation
it appeared
unbalanced
but her famous equivalents put forth by
a young swiss patent clerk showed that
mass only needed to be reconsidered as
part of the total energy of a system the
difference in mass is converted into
energy a photon
sunshine
balance restored
but
what would happen
if there were
an inherent imbalance
to the universe
our bodies
our world
entire galaxies billions of light years
beyond the milky way nearly everything
we can reach out and touch consists
of matter
however there is another kind of matter
out there a near identical twin
we call it antimatter and there is
almost none of it left
an obvious enormous imbalance stretching
out across the cosmos
yet without this imbalance
we would not
and could not
exist
at all not a single person not a single
planet
not a single star
where did this imbalance
come from
how is the observable universe packed so
densely with mata with its partner
almost entirely absent
and why did the vast cosmos seem so
perfectly balanced at its inception
yet just not
quite
[Music]
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
question when the sun dies what planets
will it consume a only mercury b mercury
and venus c mercury venus and earth
that's right either b or c scientists
can't be sure as the sun expands into a
red giant it will grow and pass venus
but earth may just survive
and so our recommendation this week is
the documentary solar superstorms 4k a
fascinating exploration of what exactly
the sun shoots at us how it affects our
daily lives and how it could lead to
severe consequences magellan tv are a
sort of netflix for documentaries with
more than 3 000 videos to choose from on
a wide range of topics and history of
the universe viewers can take advantage
of a special holiday offer buy one get
one free gift cards for an annual
membership by clicking the link in the
description
[Music]
the most famous relationship in all of
physics is often cited to be the one
between mass
and energy
e equals m c
squared c is representative of the
ultimate speed limit for anything
traveling through space and equal to
that of light if it is travelling
unencumbered through pure nothingness
as simple as it appears to be this
equation provided a fundamental basis
upon which einstein's laws of relativity
could stand
in the early years of the 20th century
the world was being ushered into a new
understanding of reality where strange
things happened at speeds and scales
unfathomable to the human mind albert
einstein was merely one of many
brilliant minds revealing how the
extremities of our universe defied
common perception
and so just a few years before einstein
rewrote the laws of nature paul durack
was born in bristol
first a student of engineering he
transitioned into mathematics earning a
phd from cambridge in 1926.
incredibly precise both in thought and
word tales of him sleeping during
lectures would end with his waking to
offer a quick and clever retort to the
speaker his advice to fellow physicist
niels bohr known for his plentiful
drafts of papers was that
you should never start a sentence
without knowing the end of it
[Music]
and from his postgraduate years and
beyond dirac's research obsession lay in
a brand new area of physics
in 1925 quantum mechanics had rewritten
our perspective of the subatomic world
particles though the only ones known at
the time with a proton and electron
could simultaneously exist and be
described mathematically
as waves
by 1926 erwin schrodinger had published
his keystone equation from quantum
reality but dirac noticed it was
incomplete
it didn't account for the effects of
einstein's relativity
someone needed to tackle this problem
diving into the math direct soon
discovered an incredible secret hiding
within the relationship between energy
and mass
e
equals m c squared
was wrong
or rather like schrodinger's quantum
model it was incomplete
merely reflective of one specific
situation when a massive particle is not
moving relative to its observer this
difference is only significant at
extreme speeds yet these speeds are
reached at the imperceptibly tiny scales
of electrons orbiting their atomic
nuclei as dirac pieced together a more
universal quantum understanding he
obtained an updated more complicated
equation which later bore his name
many years later he was asked how he
found the dirac equation it was said he
responded
i found it beautiful
[Music]
but what did this discovery actually
mean for the energy and mass of our
universe
up until this point electrons had only
been allowed to have positive energy but
within the math of this incredible
breakthrough layer surprise
they could also
have negative energy
but this created a problem
in the 1920s physicists knew that
electrons always sought to exist in the
lowest possible energy state if negative
energies were possible as dirac's
equations suggested this would mean that
zero energy was no longer the lowest
level there should be an infinite number
of negative energy states to fall into
with every electron throughout the
universe constantly spiraling downwards
and downwards into negative infinite
energy emitting infinite amounts of
light in the process
but of course that was not and is not
the case in our universe
for his equations to make sense dirac
needed something to block the electrons
he needed those negative energy levels
to already be taken
and so this infinite well of negative
energy electrons was known as the dirac
c
under dirac's hypothesis a negative
electron could occasionally get a boost
of energy such as through a collision
and become positive the hole would
mathematically act exactly like an
electron but instead have the opposite
amount of electric charge
initially dirac thought this could be
the proton discovered 30 years earlier
with its positive charge but protons are
roughly 2 000 times more massive than an
electron and thus didn't fit the bill so
durack reinterpreted his physics instead
of a proton he decided it was an
anti-electron
[Music]
it was 1931
and paul durack had proposed
antimatter
but physical proof
was still needed
[Music]
the light of distant stars is not the
only thing streaming across the universe
particles with mass do too
cosmic rays mostly composed of lonely
protons continually rain down on the
earth's atmosphere
some are created by our own sun as part
of its solar wind others may hail from
the supermassive black holes at the
center of distant galaxies
in 1931 carl anderson began his studies
of cosmic rays using a remarkable box
which could track these minuscule
particles movements
a cloud chamber an airtight box filled
with water vapor when a cosmic ray
particle streams through the chamber it
causes nearby water molecules to
condense into liquid this creates a
visible trail which provides clues about
the cosmic rays properties cloud
chambers had been used for two decades
but anderson had improved upon the
design and identified a new trail which
appeared identical to those made by
electrons but mirrored particles that
had the same mass but opposite charge
he had discovered dirac's anti-electron
and so in 1932 anderson published his
results and gave the first antimatter
particle its name
the positron
dirac c however was not long for this
world
over the decades alternate theories
about the fundamental quantum behavior
of particles would take its place
but iraq's antimatter had been proved
real
however for scientists to discover other
antiparticles they had to turn their
eyes from the sky to their own
experiments
in massive particle accelerators
powerful magnets direct charged
particles in loop after loop until they
reach intense speeds
when those particles are finely directed
to collide with a target some of the
energy in the collision converts into an
equivalent shower of massive particles
including particles too unstable to be
found elsewhere in the universe
since positrons were already relatively
rare in cosmic rays it would take a huge
amount of patience to detect heavier
anti-particles
they decided it was far more efficient
to create their own and in 1955 inside
the bevertron accelerator at lawrence
berkeley national laboratories
scientists created and discovered the
anti-proton a year later they had
revealed the anti-neutron
however it would take another four
decades before accelerated technology
was advanced enough to construct an
entire
anti-atom at the low-energy antiproton
ring at cern anti-protons flew around
their magnetically constructed ring
three million times a second each time
around they flew through a field of
xenon gas occasionally the energetic
interaction between an antiproton and
xenon atom would spontaneously create an
electron positron pair and in an even
rarer event this new positron could be
taken up by the antiproton finally
settling into an atomic orbital
and in 1995
after a three-week long experiment
nine anti-hydrogen atoms were crafted
nearly two decades later cern scientists
were able to study the properties of
anti-hydrogen specifically how it
interacted with different wavelengths of
light these experiments demonstrated
that anti-hydrogen acted exactly as
regular hydrogen would have and to all
intents and purposes scientists believe
that antimatter behaves almost
identically to normal matter
an antimatter particle would have the
same mass as its mata counterpart an
antimatter star burn just as bright
which impressively was exactly what the
work of paul durack had proposed
nearly 90 years earlier
[Music]
imagine a world where humanity could
harness the power
of antimatter
what do you see
do you see massive interstellar
starships barreling through the cosmos
expanding our reach to habitable worlds
beyond our own do you see
extraterrestrial colonies braving harsh
or eden-like environments peppered with
alien life
staring out at two setting suns
or do you see desolation the aftermath
of a technology untamed a power station
explosion that dwarfs chernobyl and
fukushima
humanity's worst traits leading us to
mutually assured destruction
either of these outlandish fates would
arise from mata antimatter reactions
being the most fuel-efficient process in
all of known physics
[Music]
through the relation between mass and
energy realized by einstein over a
century ago 100 of the mass in a matter
antimatter annihilation is converted
into energy in the form of light
gram for gram a reaction between mata
and its antimatter counterpart releases
over 100 times the energy in nuclear
reactions and 1 billion times greater
than what is released when burning
fossil fuels
there is no process in all of physics
which can do better
these days antimatter batteries engines
and warheads are the realm of science
fiction far more energy is shared in the
creation and storage of antimatter for
scientific study than is actually stored
within the antimatter's mass and thus
unusable as fuel
and though one day our descendants may
leap over these hurdles
you don't actually need to imagine a
distant future or a bizarre alien world
to interact with antimatter
in 1940 the canadian chemist martin
carman was working at the berkeley
radiation laboratory at the university
of california
his goal was straightforward by
description create a brand new version
of a very familiar element
carbon the backbone to all life as we
know it
carmen sought to create a new isotope
with hopes it could be used in medical
research
working day and night going multiple
nights without rest he and his colleague
sam ruben would irradiate samples of
graphite hoping the reaction would
convert some of the pre-existing carbon
isotopes into new ones
and on the 27th of february he finally
took a break
stepping outside the lab sleep deprived
and disheveled
but the fresh air would soon prove
a little too exhilarating a patrol car
passed by the lab the policeman inside
noticed his appearance and took him away
not for violating the rules of fashion
but because he was suspected of murder
it turned out a convict had escaped a
local prison and gone on a killing spree
carmen matched the man's description but
was eventually cleared and free to
return to his graphite samples
and it was within those samples he
finally uncovered what he sought
he and reuben had created
carbon
carbon-14
[Music]
this isotope is rare in nature but now
is famous for its use in radiocarbon
dating through which scientists can
measure the age of an object containing
organic material whether it be human
animal or plant and this is because for
every trillion carbon atoms in your body
one is carbon 14 and when you die you
stop acquiring it unlike the rest of the
carbon which was forged in the heart of
a star before our own sun was born most
carbon 14 came about much more recently
while it is oxygen gas that provides us
the breath of life our atmosphere is
mainly composed of nitrogen and
occasionally in the skies above cosmic
rays will strike a nitrogen atom
creating carbon 14. this carbon 14
combines with oxygen creating carbon
dioxide which is then incorporated into
plant life through
photosynthesis and finally it arrives
to you
as you go about life you continue to
acquire new carbon 14 keeping the total
ratio of carbon 14 in your body constant
but at the moment of your death a new
clock starts the carbon 14 decays with
nothing to replace it
the ratio drops
and scientists can use that
ever-changing ratio to measure how long
ago it was when a living thing stopped
accruing more carbon
when it died
and this decay process within the atom
is another example of the universe
seeking balance
known as beta decay while carbon 14
decay turns a neutron into a proton two
other particles have to be created
a free electron and a ghostly
anti-neutrino
as well as this as the potassium 40 in
your body decays it occasionally takes
an inverted path
creating a positron instead of an
electron and a neutrino instead of its
antimatter counterpart
in either situation or rather by both
combined through the mild radiation of
these two elements
you
and all life on earth
are natural antimatter factories
and that is just one way in which
antimatter is involved in our day-to-day
lives indeed in the 1950s scientists
began researching ways to harness
antimatter for medical imaging if a
radioactive element could be safely
injected into the human bloodstream the
circulatory system would distribute it
throughout the body as the element
decays it releases a positron the
positron quickly finds its mata
counterpart an electron and annihilates
creating two photons with a specific
amount of energy a machine capable of
detecting that energy signature would
then be able to map where in the body
the annihilation happened
this was the positron emission
tomography
or
pet scanner they are used not just for
the detection of medical disorders but
also to discern what parts of our brain
are responsible for performing certain
tasks
admiring a sunset
listening to a story
gazing
at the stars
and looking at those stars across the
greater cosmos we find yet more
antimatter
it can be ejected by violent supernovas
or the collision of dense rapidly
spinning stellar remnants called neutron
stars it has even been detected in
massive jets of radiation being fired
directly away from hungry black holes
in the 1970s astronomers detected a
cloud of positrons at the center of the
milky way and in 1997 nasa's space-based
compton gamma-ray observatory detected a
veritable fountain of antimatter
shooting 3000 light years out of our
galaxy
the source of each of these is still a
mystery and we still don't know how much
antimatter is out there waiting for us
to find it
and yet despite its surprising ubiquity
in our lives the number of antimatter
particles we have detected through the
known cosmos is vastly smaller than that
of all of the matter a simple fact that
we can thank
for our existence and the continued
existence of matter in the universe
but
as it turns out
this
is a modern imbalance
it wasn't always
this way
and turning back the clocks to the
origins of everything
we find that for a brief moment at the
dawn of the
universe things
were very different
the first antimatter formed in tandem
with the first matter
one trillionth of a second after time
itself began flowing and our known
universe came into existence
temperatures had cooled to a mere
million billion degrees celsius
there was energy
there was light there were the
fundamental forces that govern our
reality
but there was
no matter
no stuff of any substance upon reaching
this temperature milestone and following
the law of mass energy equivalence a
soup of quarks and antiquarks arose from
the sea of energy each single quark
popping into existence alongside its
antiquark twin at the same time gluons
the particles carrying the strong
nuclear force came into being in a
cooler world they would have the power
to bind quarks together but it was still
much too hot
these individual particles would zip
around randomly flying and colliding
with one another when quark and
antiquark met
they would annihilate
their mass returned to energy two
photons of light left to bound around in
the quark gluon plasma
a near total massacre of matter ever
growing the universe cooled leptons and
anti-leptons sprung forth in pairs
electrons and positrons neutrinos and
anti-neutrinos and so on but such a
decrease in temperature meant that new
quark antiquark pairs could no longer
appear from the apparent vacuum of space
those that remained were now slow enough
for the available gluons to successfully
bind them with other quarks forming
hadrons antiquarks would do the same
with their own kind forming antihedrons
the hedgerons we know best are protons
and neutrons but other more exotic and
less stable hadrons were composed too
now hadrons and their anti-hadron
counterparts protons and antiprotons
neutrons and anti-neutrons could
annihilate each other
and when the universe was one second old
the final mata antimatter particle pairs
were born of the universe's energy with
the seconds ticking away the battle
between mata and antimatter
peters out
100 seconds into all of history
mata wins
with one particle in a billion remaining
[Music]
it is now cool enough for protons and
neutrons to begin the process of
nucleosynthesis
creating new elements
for the very first time
but
according to what we understand about
the big bang the universe
never should have had this chance
mata and antimatter were created in
equal amounts thus they should have been
equally destroyed
our universe should have been set
gloriously alight with photons from the
total annihilation of all matter
not a single atom left to see that light
let alone enough to form a star or a
planet
or you
so how can we explain this fundamental
violation of balance in the universe
scientists
have some ideas
perhaps some say there is an equal
amount of antimatter out there particles
which were flung away from the war as
the universe expanded eventually forming
anti-galaxies and anti-stars in distant
regions
we know that the spectrum of an
anti-hydrogen atom looks identical to
that of hydrogen so an anti-galaxy would
be indistinguishable to our telescopes
but intergalactic winds would eventually
carry regular matter into these
anti-galaxies and astronomers have yet
to observe any light indicative of the
resulting annihilation still smaller
antimatter objects like clusters of
anti-stars could persist going about
their business for billions of years
with the antimatter they shed perceived
as just part of cosmic rays
signals
lost amid the noise
most scientists now agree that an even
stranger reality may be the answer
that in fact the universe may not in the
end have the balance
or symmetry
we long assumed it did
chen chang-woo was born in 1912 in a
small fishing town north of shanghai
unlike most chinese girls at the time
she received a formal education
attending a school for young women
founded by her own father she graduated
from a university in nanjing at the top
of her class with a degree in physics
after a few years of research her mentor
and fellow female physicist dr jin wei
gu suggested that wu emigrate to the
united states to continue her education
as she received her phd from the
university of california at berkeley in
1940.
in 1944 she relocated to new york to
join the manhattan project at columbia
university and by the mid-1950s she was
nationalized as a us citizen and an
expert in beta decay
and from that expertise she was asked to
push the boundaries of reality and
rewrite our understanding of physics
[Music]
the fundamental laws of nature at first
glance appear symmetric according to
three properties the first property is
charge we are most familiar with
electric charge associated with the
electromagnetic force
positive and negative
theoretically under charge symmetry the
positively charged up quarks and
negatively charged down quarks that
comprise protons and neutrons should be
identical in mass
and nuclear reactions should proceed
identically if using a proton or neutron
as instigator the second is parity often
thought of as handedness because your
own hands display the very concept no
matter how much you rotate it your left
hand will never be the same as your
right it is only through the use of a
mirror that you can turn one into the
other by itself the notion of parity
symmetry states that the universe has no
preferred direction to anything
but charge parity the combination of
both charge and parity symmetry dictates
that if you were to put our universe
through a mirror and replaced mata with
antimatter this new universe would look
and act identical to our own
should extraterrestrial life from that
universe deign to visit us our
telescopes would be unable to reveal
their composition until the first
contact handshake resulted in our mutual
destruction
and the third property is time time
symmetry dictates that the laws of
physics should operate the same if every
particle suddenly found its direction
speed and spin flipped to the opposite
orientation as if some cosmic hand was
hitting the rewind button on the remote
for our universe
together these principles make up cpt
symmetry upon which our fundamental
understanding of reality is based
but
what if these principles
were very slightly
broken
in 1956 chen ning yang and sung dao lee
the latter also at columbia university
proposed that parity or handedness was
asymmetric particularly in the processes
governed by the weak nuclear force
before publishing their controversial
paper lee approached dr wu to ask her if
anyone had designed an experiment to
test parity offering two ideas of his
own
she proposed a third
the experiment she suggested relied upon
a radioactive isotope of cobalt cobalt
60.
it is a synthetic compound created in
particle accelerator labs and decays by
creating both beta rays the electrons
created in beta decay as with carbon 14
and gamma rays which are high energy
photons
in wu's experiment these atoms were
constrained within a magnetic field and
cooled to extremely low temperatures
one by one the unstable nuclei would
undergo beta decay
as charged particles the electrons
created would be directed along the
magnetic field lines in one of two
directions
upwards
or downwards
if parity was conserved there would be
no preferred direction for the electrons
to go
the ratio of those going up and those
going down would be equal including when
a mirror universe was simulated by
flipping the direction of the magnetic
field
but this is not what wu's team found
instead a greater number of electrons
preferred to go against the direction of
the magnetic field no matter how it was
oriented
nature differentiated between left and
right
parity was broken
and the universe at its most basic level
was not
symmetric
unfortunately for wu her teaching duties
required her to return to new york
during the experimental period and she
was absent on the day the first
groundbreaking results came in it was
december of 1956 and the lee quickly
spread news of these preliminary results
to other scientists who within weeks
would confirm the asymmetry wu's team
had observed was true
and yet when the 1957 nobel prize in
physics was awarded
it went only to the two men behind the
theory
irrespective of this possible nobel snub
dr wu is today remembered as a
figurehead of nuclear physics and a key
contributor in revealing the universe's
asymmetry
but all this work was just the beginning
further nobel prize-winning experiments
in the second half of the 20th century
not only confirmed lee woo and yang's
results but also violated cp symmetry
the combination of charge symmetry and
parity by the end of the 20th century it
was definitive and multiple scientists
had shown that quarks and antiquarks
were being treated differently by the
laws of nature
the universe was fundamentally in an
extremely small way
out of balance
and so could this be the reason why mata
ended up outnumbering antimatter
as of now scientists believe the answer
is no
at least not entirely when adding up the
collective contribution the quark cpa
asymmetry could play in the overall
makeup of the universe scientists
realized the effect was not enough to
produce the one in a billion asymmetry
between mata and antimatter which arose
in that first second of time
so where else
must we seek
it may be that other particles are also
treated differently than their
antimatter counterparts current research
is investigating cp symmetry in the
other family of fundamental matter
particles the leptons and preliminary
results are promising
another source of the universe's mata
antimatter asymmetry may be caused by
there being another type of neutrino
which only existed at the birth of our
universe
neutrinos are cosmic phantoms which
barely interact with other matter and
have a mass of almost zero around 100
trillion pass through your body every
second having almost no effect and yet
despite this ghostly nature they may
have been a key factor in the early
battle between mata and antimatter
the proposal arises from an unbalanced
quirk in the neutrinos we observe today
just like human hands come in both left
and right-handed versions all particles
in the standard model can be described
as having a left-handed or right-handed
version this is true for both matter and
antimatter and scientists have observed
both left and right-handed versions of
every particle
except the neutrino and anti-neutrino
instead every neutrino scientists have
studied is left-handed and every
anti-neutrino is right-handed
if right-handed neutrinos are revealed
not to exist it could mean that
neutrinos are their own anti-particle or
if right-handed neutrinos do exist the
majority of them decayed long ago
so if neutrinos do not operate under cp
symmetry as early results suggest these
right-handed neutrinos could have had a
preference for what they decayed into
they could have decayed into matter more
frequently than antimatter
will this be enough to get us to that
one in a billion
it is too soon to say
for now
indeed the results may prove similar to
that of quarks the asymmetry being
insufficient
but even then all is not lost
it may still be that there are pockets
of antimatter out there never having
made contact with the rest of the
universe making the true ratio of matter
to antimatter even smaller
perhaps one day a floating slab of
antimatter could appear on the horizon
and give us our answer
before annihilating the entire earth in
a blinding flash of light
indeed aboard the international space
station a special detector is on the
hunt for the antimatter version of a
helium isotope anti-helium-3
by revealing how much antimatter can be
detected in our own cosmic backyard
within the air encircling our own cosmic
house
we might be able to extrapolate this
abundance to discover how much is out
there
and how mata
truly won the war within the first few
minutes
after the big bang
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like and
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
[Music]